a propósito del protagonismo de olivia
newton john en grease que al español se
tradujo como brillantina o vaselina que
significó esta película para los
musicales mira esta película fue
importantísima a la gente sino el día
que es básicamente una historia de amor
de dos adolescentes que se enamoren que
son conscientes que al final del verano
van a tener que poner caminos separados
pero por fuerzas del destino vuelven a
encontrarse pero lo verdaderamente
espectacular de brillantina y sobre todo
al continente latinoamericano es que nos
acercó a consumir los musicales gracias
a una banda sonora
impactante esta banda sonora era tan
buena que no dependía realmente de su
presencia en la película en sí para ser
un éxito en la radio latinoamericana la
zona hasta el cansancio todavía sigue
formando parte de lo que se llama el
catálogo de lo que suena en la radio
incluso los fines de semana en la noche
este es un éxito tremendo que se
construye a partir de la música y que
impacta a la gente en américa latina y
se conecta también y además crea moda la
gente quería verse como john travolta y
poder bailar con ellos y las mujeres
querían tener el pelo de libia no
intención era una cosa que creo muda
también y a propósito de esto cuál es el
legado de la cantante en el mundo de la
música
nos deja un sinfín de éxitos
absolutamente preciosos ahorita que
estaba mencionando física al
definitivamente uno de ellos pero ella
también es muy buena música en la década
los 70 y también trabajó la banda sonora
de xanadú entonces es esa evolución más
musical fantástica que deja de lo que
hizo incluso desde las bases del control
en los setentas a lo que encontramos un
poco identificamos también como la
música de los 80s nos deja una voz
preciosa una capacidad interpretativa
también maravillosa y muchos pero muchos
recuerdos atados a grandes canciones y
cuál fue la polémica que se dio
a propósito de physical en 1981 cuando
se lanzó porque la prohibieron pues lo
que están diciendo ahorita el tío de
física el para los para la época era muy
sexual algunas personas dicen que
incluso dice la leyenda el vídeo de
física de los lentes los juntaban con un
poquito de vaselina para que no fluyera
como tan transparente la cosa porque la
gente sudando haciendo ejercicio todos
con los torsos pues desnudos y demás eso
era pesadísimo para la época en que
salió el sencillo y además la canción
muy sugestivo decía let's get física en
un gimnasio pero todos sabemos que era
lo que quería realmente decir entonces
era eso fue controversial en su momento
de pronto hoy en día nos da risa pero
así se construyeron también parte de los
legados de la música